hello my name is Jack xolo I took simply
learned course in april of 2016 it was a
Salesforce administrator developer
course it was fantastic it was so good I
just had it right now had to make this
video because i want to share my
experiences and so i took the course and
and it was fantastic and literally about
two weeks after the course i took and
passed my Salesforce certification
course that's how thorough it was not
only was the instructor caring I mean he
wrote emails to the students about other
topics after the course during the
course he was so helpful he actually did
a lot of notes and told us which
questions might be in the exam which
questions might be in an interview I'm a
sales force interview which which
questions or you know might be asked on
the job so fantastic he went way beyond
whatever I had an issue I would either
chat and I'll get my answers right on
the spot or I would send an email i
would get an answer very quickly through
that case management system either
recording so i want to help on something
and they were just fantastic i was
amazed how quick it was so good i
actually signed up for and just finished
another course by simply learn the PMP
course on project management finish the
last class today actually fantastic so
eager to study work with the instructor
and pass the PMP test hopefully the next
you know several weeks so too good
courses so you know they have a robust
community for folks that have taken many
courses that simply learn offers and it
was fantastic i could ask questions i
could get pretty pretty quick responses
from either other students or the
instructors themselves it was fantastic
you